richard pryor was my hero and and i'm
proud to say my friend
richard and i were friends until his
last day on this earth and howard at the
end of his life
there weren't a lot of people hanging
around kissing richard's ass you're
right richard pryor at the end was sick
he couldn't perform really he he lost
his ability to talk
i imagine everyone abandoned him at that
point so what would you do would you go
and visit him and say richard how you
doing and and
check in on him that's a really good
thing to do yeah
yeah i would go i would jump over the
fence because
sometimes if the nurse was shopping or
something i'd jump over the fence and
just
go to the back window where it was his
room and
i would hang out with him it was really
cool we'd watch tv
one time he wanted to go see one of
eddie's movies so he had this little
cart
i put his cart in my range rover and
took him to the sherry lansing theater
at paramount
and we watched one of eddie's movies and
um
did you tell eddie that right away did
you say richard wanted to go to your
movie i asked richard where he wanted to
go man
he didn't want to go to the mall he
didn't want to richard he didn't want to
go to the beach richard wanted to go see
your movie man
and i told him and that made him really
happy but you know what else
with richard i would say richard are
there other things you want to do
and he'd say there are people i miss
and i said like who he said like i would
love to see quincy jones
and so i would say let me work on that
and i would literally find quincy
put him in a car and two days later
bring him to the house and sit him in a
bedroom and him and richard would hang
out
you know who else he wanted to meet one
time we were watching tv and it was
the steve harvey sitcom with cedric the
entertainer and steve
played mr hightower a teacher and
richard's looking at him
and richard said i i think i think he
kind of looks like me
and i said you know you're right richie
he went yeah the fro because steve had
his throwback
i said yeah and he says i met him once i
liked him
and i said would you like me to bring
him over he says yeah i would love to
sit
and talk with him and i
steve and i went to college so it was
easy to find him we
uh we went to kent state together found
steve put him in a car
brought him to richards left him in the
room let him and richard talk for two
hours
you know steve harvey i think he's a
really smooth
comic great television presence i don't
know that he gets his due
and the fact that he came and visited
richard he must have been beside himself
i mean anyone who gets to sit with
richard pryor
it's amazing but it's awkward too
because when he's sick
you can't talk like you have to keep the
conversation going richard can't talk
that much right so it's
it's it's weird yeah you kind of have to
talk to richard and and tell him stories
and uh you know he would laugh and he
would still respond
you know but uh he was a great dude
and he was funny howard to the last day
he was on this earth i took him
to the comedy awards one time it was a
comedy award show
and you know i help him walk out and
they gave him this lifetime achievement
award
and somebody in the balcony said we love
you richard
and richard said what suck my dick then
this is
this is when richard was sick he was
still
[Music]
richard